[Applause]
so by the way there's a big question of
whether it's tease me or t-sne so I'm
from the t-sne and part of the world so
yeah I'm sorry and that's the way I'm
going to say okay so I'm God and I'm
doing my masters in blacksmith I'm
actually doing some more theoretical
machine learning so I do Python and deep
learning for fun okay and feel free to
ask questions so if we won't have time
off the out and threading me okay so
just to start us off with a fun example
take a look at this random subset of
emojis and let's see if you can answer
some questions
so where is three o'clock guys you're
supposed to be smart okay good
and how about a really happy smiley okay
so this is slightly subjective some
people think that that guy is angry or
whatever I think is happy okay good so
it took you some time right and if it
would be like four or five times as many
as emojis then it would be even harder
so this is just one cute example of how
something very simple like visualization
can help also to like communicate data
in a fun way so here you can see that
even though this was completely
unsupervised okay all I'm using here is
the visual similarity essentially I'm
getting kind of label information okay
you can see that there's like a huge
area of the clocks and a huge area of
the Smiley's okay right so what I'm
going to talk about today there's going
to be like 15 20 minutes tops of
theoretical foundations there's going to
be so much so I hope you won't be too
upset with me
then we'll talk about when you run it in
practice what are the good things you
should look out for and give you some
practical tips and finally I hope we'll
have time to talk about it I'll mention
two pretty cool example cases applique
which I think are like creative uses of
something like this okay okay so
everyone knows what visualization is
right we've done it in Excel for like 20
years 26 in okay okay but what is the
problem with these types of
visualizations that we know and love
like histograms or scatter plots okay so
I got written here essentially every
time I can only capture either one or
two variables at a time so imagine my
data is like 1,000 or 2,000 dimensions
which today makes perfect sense right
it's not that uncommon then I'll have to
do like mm squared scatter plots just to
see how all the variables interact okay
so firstly the question that we're going
to follow today in we're looking sums up
for some good visualization method the
scale to high dimension okay I want to
get either one or two maps that give me
a good understanding of what my data
looks like okay
I just noticed now that he doesn't have
an ear so I'm sorry for all the cat
lovers out there
okay so let's formulate the problem that
we're going to talk about so my example
instances my input are x1 until xn okay
think about like n images from illness
just to to get example and these
examples are in high dimension okay so
each X I can be in like are 1000 okay
and my goal is to convert every such
example X I into an example why I the
sits in a much lower dimension okay what
do I mean by low dimension is at or 3d Y
2 or 3 yeah because we're humans and
that's what most of us can grasp ok and
obviously there's a million ways to do
this right so what I'll be looking for
is the way that preserves is much of the
structure that I had in the original
dimensions in the lower dimensional
embedding okay this is it always
possible to preserve all the structures
no ok obviously
losing tons of information when I'm
doing the dimensionality reduction so
what I'll tries to lose the information
that I can afford to lose
okay that's supposed to make sense yeah
it will be clearing to slice but that's
a good question a good question is the
one I have a slide for as you of course
know okay so a national question at this
point which is usually what I get then
okay basically all you've told us is a
problem of doing dimensionality
reduction and so that we have PCA right
a great algorithm for dimensionality
reduction I'm guessing most of you're
familiar with it is that cool
great PCA just essentially project the
data onto a lower dimensional subspace
in a way that maximizes the variance
hopefully if you didn't know that
explanation help you okay so before I
talk about why PCA is bad let's see an
example so what I've done here is I've
took the digits from Emily's okay which
you can see on the left if you don't
remember so every example fits in in
this case it's 28 by 28 image grayscale
which means 28 squared in terms of
dimension I projected it onto its first
two principal components and then I
plotted it here with color coding for
the labels okay and what do you guys
think is this a good visualization why
not because I said it's gonna be about
visualization great okay so just before
we say it's very bad we can see that it
does some good things right you can see
that it does manage to completely
separate the zeros from the ones right
the red left and orange right but
everything in the middle is just really
like jumbled up okay and in an actual
real-world scenario I don't even have
the color coding of the labels right I
do this type of thing just when I want
to understand how my data looks like
when I don't have the labels and in this
case you're correct that this is
absolutely meaningless okay so this is
the problem that we're trying to fix
okay so why specie a not what we want so
Stovall something to remember is that
essentially it's a linear projection in
the end so if this transformation is not
linear that I will be incapable of
expressing it using PCA which really the
more important thing and you might have
to think about it a little and and
convince yourself later that when you
maximize the variance which is the
objective in PCA really what you're
doing is focusing on preserving the
large distances okay and by that I mean
making sure that if two points were far
apart in the original dimension we will
also be far apart in the embedding this
actually okay and the question that I'm
posing now is is that really what we
want when we're doing visualization okay
and I claim that the answer is no okay
and this is an observation that actually
the more complex the datasets are the
more higher-dimensional they are
actually the large distances are less
indicative of the structure okay so this
is just an example of the Swiss roll
okay I just took it from like
scikit-learn or whatever and you can see
here that's really the structure comes
from for example the blue points being
close together and the red points being
close together
not so much the distance between the
actual layers okay I can make it like
wider the distances the the large
distances would grow but the structure
would remain the same okay so basically
what we've said until now is PCA focuses
on the wrong type of task okay so what
would be the good type of task focusing
on maintaining the small distances then
the neighboring information okay and
that's what SNe does so I'm going to
talk about XNA t-sne is just a small
variant of it so you don't need to worry
about that for now so I say stands for
stochastic name-brand bedding and as its
name suggests it tries to map the
neighbors okay tries to make sure that
if two points were neighboring in the
high dimension they will also be
neighbors in the embedding okay and
basically what I've told you
now that's the objective that we kind of
want to have and remember that we've
said that you have to make some
sacrifices okay you can't map all the
distances so let's try to make the
sacrifices where where we can allow it
okay and this is going to be like two
minutes of - three minutes of the
mathematical part so you can listen if
you want and do something else if you
don't so how does the algorithm actually
work in practice maybe now I'll get to
the part it works okay okay so basically
for every point X I in the data set I
Center a multivariate Gaussian around it
like so and then for all the other
points XJ I choose a value of PJ I which
is supposed to represent the structure
okay following to your question by
looking at the value of the density okay
so if two points are far away okay this
will be X I and XJ will be somewhere
over here the value of the density is
very low okay so I'm going to have a
value near zero if on the other hand I
take two points they don't need I'm
going to have a value that is large
okay so just remember that there is an
inverse relationship okay to close
points would have a high value in their
density and otherwise
it's a good question I don't wanna talk
about it a bit later but if you still
have questions we'll talk okay so
basically what I'm saying now is do this
procedure that I've just described for
everything on point X I that you got in
your data set okay this will give me a
conditional density PJ condition on I
the expression on the top okay that's
what I said this mathematical stuff is
just the centering of the Gaussian okay
and now what I'm saying is for every
potential guess of a of an embedding Y I
can do exactly the same thing right I
can again calculate the distance between
every two points and this time I'm going
to call it Q since it will be a
different density okay does that make
sense
okay now I'm asking you if I were in an
ideal case where I was able to maintain
all the similarities okay my embedding
is great what would be the relationship
between the induced Q and my original P
great there will be exactly the same
okay so this introduces a very natural
cost function for algorithm right I want
to find a mapping such as the Q that
will be induced by it will be as close
to P as possible okay and this the
formulation is okay those edges are not
supposed to be there so this is just the
formulation okay by taking the distance
because P and Q are both densities that
I'm taking the appropriate distance
measure in this case it's KL divergence
okay and I'm just looking at the type at
the distance between these two and that
is that what I want to minimize okay the
expansion on the right is just opening
up the expression for KL divergence okay
okay so how do I actually solve it in
practice I've described the cost
function what do I do next
it appears in for like one second but
I'm guessing you didn't read it I want
to minimize it yeah how do I do it
stuff laughing okay it doesn't have to
be have to get gradient descent right
okay and I just
start from one initial guess and then I
keep making choosing a better embedding
that will minimize the cost function by
going in a direction opposite to the
gradient okay all of you should know it
from like deep learning or whatever I
minimize this expression here I want to
choose them yeah I didn't write the
differentiation just because it's it's a
long procedure but the parameter is Q it
will be induced by my choice of y1 until
okay cool it's not convex and I will
talk about it
good you're asking the right questions
okay
so just one final slide that I really
want to drive the point home of the fact
that SNe focuses on the local structure
so let's take a better look at this
expression on the right so you can see
that I've denoted the error term okay
the log of P over Q essentially every
time I'm making a mistake in in the
structure I'm going to pay something in
this error term right because Q will not
be identical to P okay and you can see
that this error term has a weight which
is P okay so this weight is not
symmetric okay and it comes from the
fact that the KL divergence is not a
symmetric function okay P and Q don't
enter it in the same way so essentially
what I'm saying here is that the same
error okay the same error in Q to P will
be will be like paralyzed differently
okay higher values of P will be a
mistake that is much more costlier to
make and when do I have high values of P
PJ I remember from two sides ago
great okay so essentially what it means
that close points being mapped to far
points okay this type of error will have
pji which is high and it's going to pay
a very high penalty so that's to think
that this SME objective is going to try
to avoid most okay doesn't mean that I'm
not gonna that I don't care about
mapping far points I still want to map
for points correct but I don't care as
much about them okay which is why I
wrote SNe focuses on preserving the
local structure okay yeah yes and that
that is the number one problem with SNe
you're absolutely right so T t-sne
solves that and that's why it's the
popular version today if I have time
I'll mention it cool okay so just to see
an example so on the left is the same
PCA from before and on the right is the
result of applying SNA on the first five
digits of M Ness okay and you can see
that in terms of the improvement it's
like zero to one right it's almost a
clear separation except the fact like
you mentioned that there isn't that
significant separation between the
actual clusters okay but another nice
thing that you can actually see if you
look at the ones for example even the
orientation is preserved okay the ones
that are facing this way are far apart
from the ones that are facing that way
okay so this is like near near perfect
result and this is t-sne okay with what
I've mentioned it does a better job of
pushing them far apart and this is the
stochastic result of this procedure so
you can see here if I were sorry that it
keeps trying I always think about it two
seconds later even if I were now to make
the points black okay would you discard
the label information you can really
make so much sense from this
visualization okay and it's completely
unsupervised if you can look at this and
know that there are like ten
eleven natural clusters in this dataset
so obviously it's like emesis today
almost a toy example but it's still I
think it's still pretty impressive
good questions okay so we're done with
the last good job yeah
in what way limited computationally okay
so actually computationally um the
factories and they became as famous as
it is today and the number one go-to is
because there's a very fast
approximation method that essentially
you pay very little in the air but the
the algorithm runs in n log n so n log n
can scale perfectly well into like 10 K
examples right so so 10 K it's not that
little something you can do for for
larger is just like either sample or
like just choose randomly to plot some
part of the data set and if you have ten
hours then you can run the entire 70 K
digits of M list it's considered pretty
fast and I've used it in like production
as well no that's a great question okay
he asked if there's a function actually
mapping me from X to Y and the answer is
no t-sne because the fact that I'm just
at every iteration I'm just guessing
there's no like parametric function the
transforms which from X to Y in a way I
think it's it's an advantage okay some
people are nodding I don't know no I I'm
just if you want to do parametric
estimation then you have to assume a lot
about the kind of structure that the
mapping will have and then you are
limited in what you can express in a way
so t-sne can do good results on complex
datasets because it assumes very little
okay I'm gonna go ahead okay so it's
another cat meme
okay so let's dig into the price on
implementation it's not as interesting
but I think it is useful to know in case
you do want to like go home and do it
okay so a number of components is just
either two or three D right then
embedded space dimension perplexity so
we'll ask sit here before remember that
I said we Center a Gaussian around it so
you can ask how do I choose the right
value for the for the Gaussian so it
comes like in the form of choosing the
perplexity value so it's something that
you as the user should do just keep in
mind that it's supposed to denote the
effective number of neighbors that every
example has in the data set so try to
think about the data set that you're
working with and choose a value that is
appropriate honestly I've gotten very
good results without tweaking this
parameter and they also mention it in
the article so feel free to do it but
you don't have to early exaggeration
just means how close natural clusters
will be in the embedded space okay if
you want a more spaced out visualization
and choose a higher value for this okay
learning rate this goes back to one
guy's question KL divergence is not
convex so the objective function that I
showed before is not convex and we're
solving it with a tool gradient descent
that essentially means that the only
guarantee I have is in terms of reaching
a local minimum right okay and that can
obviously very be very problematic
because I don't know how this lost
manifold looks like and if it has very
bad local minimums then I essentially
have no guarantee over the quality of my
mapping
okay so DSN itself does some like in
like optimization tricks to avoid this
momentum and like adding a random noise
people should be familiar with it oh
yeah exactly simulated annealing um one
thing that you can actually do to help
it is to make sure that the learning
rate is tweaked appropriately
just like in the internal networks this
is just the initialization of the
embedding what your first guess will be
the random or PCA random state just keep
in mind because this is a stochastic
procedure every time you run it you'll
get a different map so if you want to
like if you got this one good map and
you want to do it again then make sure
you you control the seed of the
pseudo-random generator just so you can
reproduce the result
standard in every method today in
scikit-learn and this is what I said
before the approximation method is
called burns hot I really recommend
always using it it's much faster and you
don't pay a lot in terms of beer
questions cool ok so I actually run into
this algorithm like I think it was six
months ago
and it solved it was like out of the box
really for like the took two minutes I
got amazing results on my images I was
like whoa great algorithm and then I
read the article and I was like it's
also a cool algorithm it has some nice
intuition behind it and then I I try to
understand like does it really solve the
problem of dimensionality touching does
it answer every case so I asked this
question on cross validated which is
like the statistical brother of Stack
Overflow and I got a lot of uploads and
I was happy because I had refutation but
no one really answered my question
so I had to go do it on my own and this
is actually I think it's a nice lesson
when whenever you stumble upon a new
algorithm if you want to really
understand it try to understand the
cases it doesn't solve okay and how
would you go about doing them okay so
one of the things that can be useful is
try to take a very close look at the
implicit and explicit assumptions that
the algorithm makes okay
usually the writers of the table has a
very strong inclination to
brush this off okay because they want to
make it look like it it's always good so
so you need to take a good look at it
okay and one of the main really only
assumption the t-sne makes is the local
linearity assumption
okay essentially remember when we
calculate CLE we we use the Euclidean
distances between every pair of two
points okay and by doing this
essentially what we're saying is that
locally okay when you zoom in to the to
the function enough to the points enough
then they sit on a linear manifold if
it's gibberish to you then don't worry
okay so let's look at the cases in which
the local linearity assumption doesn't
hold
okay so one really nice staircase is
when you have very noisy data okay when
you have very noisy data then there is
no nice manifold because you have a lot
of like divergence okay and in this case
the solution is just to smooth the data
okay just apply PCA before your fight is
any and actually if you look at the
documentation and scikit-learn they
recommend doing it every time year they
say doom PCA 250 and then do lndhu t-sne
50 in terms of dimension yeah dude first
50 but with PSPs in and due to to its
t-sne yes it's basically what I said now
and we can talk about it afterwards
which one
ah fortunately I you're right I forgot
okay in the other case the other case
it's it's a bit more difficult I don't
want to get into it too much but
sometimes there can be datasets they're
so complex that they have a very high
intrinsic dimension okay you really you
can't do a dimensionality reject
reduction without losing too much of the
information okay it's almost like a non
solvable problem so in this case you
kind of have to make
datasets simpler and that's something
that you can do very well today with
auto-encoders okay just choose a code
length which is the intrinsic dimension
that you want something that will be
simple enough for t-sne to handle pass
the data before to the auto encoder then
do t-sne I didn't have to do it so I
think it's like pretty crazy cases but
keep this in mind
okay so just final tips for this part I
choose the right perplexity value I said
it even though it's not that critical
but okay
remember that it's a stochastic
procedure okay so if you're doing
deployment don't just put out one math
because it might be the one that is like
the worst at least check the value of
the cost function make sure you do
interpret the map of t-sne with some
caution okay because you can get some
nice-looking patterns even in just
random randomly generated data so make
sure you don't automatically go like wow
amazing I have so much structure in my
data and it's actually just gibberish
and remember the the fail cases okay
which I've talked about yes yeah I'm
pretty sure you can I I actually got
good Maps every time so I didn't have to
do it I I did it on images so I could
visualize the result okay so now I'm
going to talk about the two example
applications the first doll is very
straightforward but very visually
appealing and this is actually how I got
to TSN in the first place I was required
to like someone told me do this and then
I was like I don't know how to do it I
did PC and the results were crap okay so
basically what we've done here is this
is the work of cotati
he took images in this case it's images
from imagenet but it doesn't have to be
he passed them through a pre trained
network okay he took the final layer as
the deep features okay and if you don't
know then the final layer of the neural
network is it's trained properly it's
supposed to have a lot of like semantic
information okay so if I take two
butterflies they are supposed to be
similar in those representations okay
there are four
thousand ninety six vectors are supposed
to be fairly close to each other so this
is a natural case for Tiffany okay I
want to make sure that if two examples
were close in the high dimension they
will still be close in the low dimension
and then I and then he snapped the
results to this nice-looking regular
grid and imagine that you're like a
company doing some sort of image
retrieval or a search engine for Images
organizing the results in such a way for
the user this is this goes back to the
smiling example I think it has a lot of
stuff to gain okay it's very easier to
find what you want
in this example okay I will be I work
also at cellebrite and which is like a
digital forensics company and basically
we have like millions of images and the
the investigator the guy from the police
he wants to find like something
suspicious and this is useful to take a
look at the images of a single person
and really understand his hobbies and
what he's into and if he has like nudity
or stuff like that you can see it in you
can look at it in five seconds and get a
really good understanding of what that
person looks like what his hobbies are
ok the second application is also
related to deep learning ok so I'm
working an invite one of the project
that is a biology related I'm using deep
learning to predict glucose values and
then I'm using t-sne quite a lot so one
thing I'm doing for example is I want to
try to understand is something some
attribute okay like gender is my network
the one that I've trained is it using
this information or not okay it goes
back to the question of inter-facility
which she keeps saying neural networks
are bad because they're not
interpretable so there are things that
you can do so for example one thing that
I'm doing is I'm I'm taking like 1,000
males and 1,000 females passing them
through the network taking one of the
features from one of the layers plotting
them on TSA and I'm looking at
there are pr2 natural clusters okay if
two natural clusters appear essentially
I know that TSN a with my algorithm
sorry that my network not easily uses
this gender information it encodes it in
the representation okay but I don't want
to talk about that because it's fairly
straightforward and nothing special
about it
and nicer work is something called meta
SNe so what I've said now is do t-sne on
the representations what method SNe does
is goes one level of abstraction higher
abstraction I don't know how safe
obstruction okay and essentially do
t-sne
on the space of representations okay and
if that doesn't make sense then think
about one neural network okay it has
like ten twenty 120 layers every layer
is a different representation of my
original data okay what I can do is I
can try to understand how two
representations are similar or
dissimilar okay it will give you an idea
of what's going on inside the network
and another good reason to do it is that
you can use this to answer the question
suppose I have two models that they
achieve similar results okay the losses
are similar the accuracy is similar I
can use this to figure out if on the
inside they're also doing similar things
when they're doing their prediction okay
which i think is is pretty important
yeah there is some it's kind of a
statistic that I built from this layer
it's a bit you can read it in the blog
and yeah I put the link I didn't make it
up here it's some guy made it up okay so
here you can see on the right the the
example so this is like a couple of
different neural networks trained on em
nice and actually it the groupings so I
forgot to put the legend but the yellows
are
I think sigmoid layers and the the pink
are consonants layer cons layer and the
red are values okay so essentially it
means that every different like type of
activation or or layer makes the data
look in a different manner I'm sorry
it's not clear less but you should read
the blog it goes into great detail about
it it's my last slide so I want to be on
time and if you have any questions yeah
yeah someone clapped outside
[Applause]